اذا سنوات من الضربات التي تواجهها توجهها
اسرائيل فعليه للمواقع الايرانيه داخل
سوريا وهدفها كما تقول من علم الميليشيات
الايرانيه من التمدد اضافه لمنع تهريب
السلاح الى حزب الله لبنان
بحسب مصدر استخباراتيه من دوله متحالفه مع
الولايات المتحده بان ايران سعد الى
انشائي شبكه دفاع جوي شامله في سوريا
مشيرا الى انها قامت فعلا بارسال معدات
وافراد لانشائي هذا النظام المصدر كشف ان
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه تغيرت اخره عامين
حيث قام الطهران بتعزيز نشري قدراتي دفاع
جوي لصالحها في سوريا بتكلفه وصلت لعشرات
الملايين من الدولارات
تم كم مشروع المشترك مع قوات النظام
السوري بهدف في زرع النظام الايراني
المستقل للدفاع الجوي داخل سوريا
دون النظام في تحديث مجموعه من الرادارات
الخاصه بهم وشملت الاسلحه صاروخ صياد الذي
يعمل بالوقود اربعه بي- الصلب وتم دمج
القديفه مع نظام صواريخ بافار 373 ارجو
ويقال ان مداها يزيد عن 186 ميلا مع مدى
رادار يزيد عن 280 ميلانو
[موسيقى]
والان قائد مجموعه فاجنر يقول انه قواته
اثرت على جثه احد البريطانيين اللذين اعلن
عن اختفائهما في وهما متطوعان في اوكرانيا
بناء على بيان صابر
عن منظومات الدفاع الجوي الايرانيه التي
يتم تركيبها تحديدا على الاراضي السوريه
قرب قوات النظام هو ما جعل الاخيره تحت
خطر الضربات الاسرائيليه
حيث تم استهداف خلال العامين الماضيهين
فقط بحسب تقارير سبع شبكات ايرانيه للدفاع
الجوي في سوريا بما في ذلك في تدمر وترطوس
في اكتوبر 20 21 والذيقيه في ديسمبر 20 21
ودمشق في مارس 20 22 وضاربه اضافيه في
طرطوس في يوليو 20 22 اضافه الى ضربتين في
حمص في نوفمبر وديسمبر 28
وعلى مدار سنوات القليله الماضيه همم قتل
10 ايرانيين في غارات جويه اسرائيليه في
سوريا وتم تحديد ايرانيين قتل في القاره
الجويه في مارس من عامه 20 22 وهما مرتضى
سعيد نجاد واحسان كربلاء
كلاهما مهندسا دفاع جويريه
[موسيقى]